[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer
hier ist Mirko Kasimir und hier ist
Stefan Netzeband damit wieder einmal
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland heute geht es bei uns um
einen versuchten Mord immerhin nur
versucht aber auch um einen der unter
Juristen berühmtesten Prozesse der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland ganz genau es
geht um den Weltuntergang ja ich vergaß
den Weltuntergang und den Katzen König
und genau das ist das Stichwort als
katzenkönigfall ist diese Geschichte
unter Juristinnen und Juristen und allen
die sich aus welchen Gründen auch immer
mit Gerichtsprozessen oder
Rechtswissenschaften beschäftigen
bekannt geworden dass wir euch in dieser
Folge erzählen hat Einzug in die Jura
Fachliteratur gefunden es berührt die
Frage nach mittelbarer und unmittelbarer
Schuld nach direkter Täterschaft
einerseits und Anstiftung seelischem
Terror Ausnutzung von Gefühlen und
Erpressung andererseits Mirko los am
Abend des 30 Juli 1986 läutet es an der
Wohnungstür der 33-Jährigen Floristin
Annemarie n in Bochum vor der Tür steht
Michael R mit dem sie flüchtig bekannt
ist er ist damals 28 Jahre alt und ein
Polizeibeamter aus der Gegend er bittet
Annemarie enfreundlich noch einmal kurz
ihren Laden zu öffnen um ihm einige
Schnittblumen rote Rosen zu verkaufen
Annemarie n hat zwar eigentlich schon
Feierabend ihr Sohn und eine Freundin
sind auch in der Wohnung aber einem
jungen Mann der rote Rosen braucht kann
man doch diesen Wunsch nicht einfach
abschlagen außerdem ist der Laden im
gleichen Gebäude die Sache wird also nur
ein paar Minuten dauern sie nimmt
Michael Arm mit zum Geschäft schließt
auf die beiden gehen hinein und
unvermittelt zieht Michael R ein Messer
und sticht auf sie ein wieder und wieder
auf den Körper den Hals das Gesicht dann
wird es schwarz und still um sie herum
oh mann das ist unglaublich ein Mann
dessen Beruf es ist Menschenleben zu
schützen und Gewalt zu verhindern
versucht eiskalt hinterhältig ohne
Vorwarnung und scheinbar ohne Grund eine
Frau zu töten zehnmal sticht er auf die
Blumenhändlerin ein aber Annemarie n
überlebt ihr Sohn und die Freundin eilen
zu Hilfe und retten ihr so
wahrscheinlich das Leben Michael richtet
wird aber gleich am nächsten Morgen von
seinen Kollegen verhaftet
als er erfährt dass Annemarie n noch
lebt scheint eine Welt in ihm
zusammenzubrechen
denn eigentlich müsste nun die ganze
Welt in sich zusammenstürzen das Böse
müsste aus der Hölle aufsteigen und die
gesamte Menschheit mit sich in die
Dunkelheit reißen und die Zeit des
mächtigen katzenkönigs würde beginnen
aber irgendwie ist es einfach nur der
Sommer 1986
naja der Sommer 86 hatte es andererseits
aber auch ganz schön in sich drei Monate
vorher war Block 4 im Kernkraftwerk
Tschernobyl explodiert saurer Regen und
Waldsterben Ozonloch und der schwählende
kalte Krieg ließen die Parole der
Punkbewegung wie eine Prophezeiung
wirken no future aber wir Menschen sind
sehr gut darin Dinge zu verdrängen und
ja trotz aller Untergangs Propheten
trotz Wolf malen der in den deutschen
Chart sagen oh wow Tschernobyl das
letzte Signal vor dem Overkill Couch ein
schlimmer Reim Mirko obwohl du dir
solche Mühe gegeben hast ja sorry das
Lied ist auch mal zum schlechtesten
Protest Song aller Zeiten gekürt worden
und ähm wie ich finde zu Recht wenn ihr
wirklich Schmerz befreit und hart im
Leben seid dann googelt einfach mal
danach aber jedenfalls trotz all dieser
gefahren und düsteren Aussichten ist es
für die meisten eben doch einfach nur
der Sommer 1986 und Modern Talking
Samantha Fox und Level 42 stehen
wesentlich höher in den Hitparaden als
Tschernobyl Overkill ich könnte jetzt
noch lessons in Love von Level 42
anstimmen mache ich aber nicht für
einige sind diese Katastrophen und
Krisen der Zeit denn nur Vorboten und
Zeichen des nahenden Weltuntergangs und
der sicheren Auslöschung der Menschheit
einige Jahre vor dem Verbrechen
1982 nämlich lernt Michael r die damals
18-Jährige Barbara Haken der junge
Polizist war schon als Kind ein etwas
verschrobener und ein etwas
außenseiterisch begabter Mensch und das
ist im Beruf nicht viel besser geworden
im Gegenteil die Kollegen meiden ihnen
da sie nicht so wirklich etwas mit ihm
anfangen können Michael R ist
spielsüchtig hat Schulden und hängt
häufig in düsteren Kneipen ab in einer
dieser Kneipen lernt er 1982 Barbara ha
kennen die beiden kommen ins Gespräch
und die junge Frau erzählt ihm ihr
ganzes Leben mit ihren gerade mal 18
Jahren sagt sie hat sich schon die Hölle
auf Erden erlebt ihr Ex-Freund Udo n
habe sie zur Abtreibung gezwungen seit
den traurige sie um ihr ungeborenes Kind
sie sei zur Prostitution gezogen und
noch minderjährig an freier in Paris
verkauft worden und nun vor eben diesen
Peinigern auf der Flucht eine wirklich
dramatische Geschichte kriminelle eines
weltumspannende den Zuhälter Rings
versuchen immer wieder sie zu kidnappen
zu foltern und zu vergewaltigen Michael
ist Instinkt als Polizist und Beschützer
erwacht
ist er da einer großen Sache auf der
Spur hier wird doch Hilfe von ihm
benötigt ja ganz sicher er kann sich gut
vorstellen dass diese selbstbewusste
Frau bedroht wird ja es kann nur so sein
wie sie es erzählt und ja er wird sie
beschützen ich kann mir das schon
irgendwie vorstellen da hast du diesen
ziemlich eigenbrötlerischen Mann und
hier scheint er eine Frau gefunden zu
haben die einem wie ihm vertraut auf
persönlicher und irgendwie auch
beruflicher Ebene Michael fühlt sich
gebraucht und respektiert die beiden
wird schnell so etwas wie Freunde bald
sieht auch Michael rüber als Zeichen
Indizien und Muster dafür dass man
Barbara auf den Fersen ist
Verdächtige Passanten abgedunkelte
Limousinen und zu neugierige Nachbarn
aber auch Kontaktanzeigen in Zeitungen
die als verschlüsselte
Kommunikationsmittel unter den
Kriminellen dienen sollen Barbara die
femvatal in den verruchten Schoß von
Paris zurückholen nein nicht mit ihm
Michael R ist zu clever zu wachsam und
einfach ein guter Polizist das denkt er
auf jeden Fall er organisiert
Personenschutz für sie offiziell geht
das nicht Michael übernimmt es selbst
und er engagiert bekannte um ihn in
seiner Abwesenheit zu vertreten er
schlägt sich die Nächte um die Ohren und
sieht immer mehr Puzzleteile eines
riesigen kriminellen Geflecht ist und
falls ihr euch fragt nein es ist keine
sexuelle Beziehung Michael ist ganz
Freund und Helfer in dieser Freundschaft
richtig das Verhältnis zu Barbara bleibt
platonisch er ist ihr Beschützer und
selbst einander hält sie scheint zu
schwer traumatisiert auf körperlicher
Ebene will sie mit Männern nichts mehr
zu tun haben er muss sie einfach nur
umsorgen und sehen wie es sich
entwickelt und es entwickelt sich
prächtig für Barbara ausgelaugt von
Dienst und den vielen Stunden als
privater Personenschützer taucht Michael
einmal unvermittelt in Barbaras Wohnung
auf dort erwartet ihn ja da erwartet ihn
gewissermaßen was unerwartet ist einer
der freiwilligen Bewacher der jungen
Frau legt den persönlichen Schutz sehr
sehr persönlich aus er erwischt die
beiden nämlich im Barbaras Bett die
Entdeckung stürzt Michael R in eine
tiefe emotionale Krise schlagartig wird
ihm bewusst dass er von Barbara
ausgenutzt und schlichtweg verarscht
wurde seine Zeit sein Geld und seine
Reputation als Polizist sind dahin
verdampft im fanatischen waren der allem
Anschein nach erlogenen Geschichte einer
Frau die gern im Mittelpunkt steht er
bricht die Beziehung ab und will sie nie
wiedersehen aber ihr ahnt es natürlich
sieht er sie wieder irgendwann Ende 1985
Anfang 86 und wieder mal in einer Kneipe
und Barbara ist nicht allein ein Mann in
den 40ern ist bei ihr offensichtlich
sind die beiden ein Paar und ganz
ehrlich Mirko wenn ich das in unseren
Unterlagen lese warum zum Teufel setzt
er sich trotzdem wieder an diesen Tisch
zu dieser Frau wo ihm das eigentlich
alles klar sein muss also zu ihrem neuen
Lover mit an den Tisch ich verstehe
nicht was in der antreibt
tja und wieder versinkt er in ihren
Geschichten die er doch eigentlich nicht
mehr glauben wollte und die Geschichten
sind inzwischen noch um einiges
erstaunlicher geworden das kann man wohl
sagen denn ihr neuer Freund Peter P
damals 43 Jahre alt der hat sie in die
Welt des Okkultismus eingeführt sie sei
so erzählt sie jetzt Michael eine
Hohepriesterin ihre Seele sei viel älter
als ihr Körper und stamme von den
Bewohnern des versunkenen Atlantis ab
geheime Symbole in okkulten Büchern
würden all dies eindeutig beweisen
Barbaras Freund Peter ist seine
ruhepriesterin völlig verfallen und auch
Michael ist fast sinniert und verstrickt
sich bald wieder heillos in Barbaras
Geschichten und findet überall die
Bestätigung die er so dringend braucht
um ihr zu glauben
sind das nicht versteckte Nachrichten
von Zuhältern da in den Zeitungsannoncen
alles ergibt Sinn die Verfolgung durch
die Zuhälter ist eigentlich das Böse das
in Barbara eine Gefahr für seinen
mörderisches Streben erkennt diese
dunklen Mächte wollen verhindern dass
Barbara wahrhaftig erwacht und die
Menschheit retten kann es entwickelt
sich eine eigenartige Dreierbeziehung
das Gericht wird es später ein von
Mystizismus Schein Erkenntnis und
Irrglauben geprägtes neurotisches
Beziehungsgeflechten nennen
gemeinsam lesen Sie Bücher schauen Filme
und identifizieren täglich neue Symptome
einer Zeit des Untergangs die
Katastrophen des Jahres 1986 zeigen in
ihren Augen eindeutig und mit brennenden
Lanzen dass die Zeit gekommen ist die
Zeit des katzenkönigs
Werbung du Marius ja ich liebe ja die
TV-Serie julia Leischik sucht bitte
melde dich die schaue ich ja am liebsten
mit meiner Mama zusammen denn in dieser
Serie geht es darum dass die Julia quasi
um die halbe Welt fliegt um vermisste
Menschen zu suchen und Familien die
lange Zeit voneinander getrennt waren
die wieder zusammenzuführen und das
macht sie jetzt schon seit sage und
schreibe 18 Jahren und ich kann dir eins
sagen bei uns auf der Couch daheim
bleibt kein Auge trocken das kann ich
mir sehr gut vorstellen aber Rakel weißt
du was ich erzähle dir jetzt mal was es
gibt das ganze nämlich jetzt auch zum
Hören im brandneuen Podcast julia
Leischik spurlos echt jetzt erzähl mir
mehr ja jede Woche gibt es einen neuen
rätselhaften und emotionalen Fall ne wie
du das kennst Julia erzählt das zusammen
im Podcast aber mit ihrem langjährigen
Kollegen Michael Strasser und ich finde
hört man sofort das ist eine
eingefrorenes Team ne die beiden sind
schon seit so vielen Jahren zusammen
unterwegs fürs Fernsehen reisen um die
ganze Welt um diese Vermissten zu suchen
da hörst du einfach dass es natürlich
auch Freunde geworden sind aber nicht
nur die beiden kommen zu Wort sondern
auch direkt betroffene Angehörige
Kriminalbeamte Experten und die
schildern dann alle ihre Sicht auf den
Fall also liefern sie quasi einen Blick
hinter die Kulissen genau ja also man
kann sagen das ist so eine True Crime
wie sie da den Fällen nachgehen trifft
auf große Emotionen wie easy liebt da zu
Hause auf der Couch der Podcast julia
Leischik spurlos jeden Mittwoch gibt es
eine neue Folge also hört auf jeden Fall
rein und um keine Folge zu verpassen
abonniere die julia Leischik spurlos
kostenlos auf dem Podcast Player eures
Vertrauens
Werbung Ende
okay den Katzenkönig kennen die meisten
von euch vermutlich nicht also ist es
vielleicht Zeit ihn ein bisschen
vorzustellen also hallo Hörer
Katzenkönig gestatten Katzenkönig Hörer
Chats beiseite das ist eine der vielen
verschwörungsmythen die damals auch wo
waren in der Katzenkönig Geschichte wird
das Böse also quasi in einer in einer
Mieze wiedergeboren also schwarzer Kater
Teufel und so naja mit
verschwörungsmythen haben wir ja auch
schließlich heute noch genug zu tun und
damals ohne Internet verbreiten sich
solche Erzählungen über Bücher VHS
Videos Audiokassetten und selbst
kopierte Pamphlete der Katzenkönig nimmt
unter diesen Mythen eine besondere Rolle
ein es ist nämlich eine sehr exklusive
Geschichte von der außerhalb der
verschworenen drei kaum jemand gehört
hat komisch eigentlich sie ist ja recht
originell wobei nach meinem Geschmack
ich hätte glaube ich eigentlich gerne
zum Beispiel einen kleinen hühnerkönig
aber auf jeden Fall muss man sagen dass
das ganze ziemlich harmlos klingt ja ja
Stefan ganz im Gegenteil denn die Sache
ist alles andere als harmlos das ist
offensichtlich wenn man an den
versuchten Mord denkt zu dem das alles
führen wird aber auch schon vorher läuft
da eine ganz üble Nummer und ihr Opfer
ist der spätere Täter Michael R das
klingt zwar launig aber Peter P und
Barbara manipulieren den augenscheinlich
leichtgläubigen Michael immer mehr sie
führen ihn mir ziemlich billigen
Effekten und Tricks sind das Licht immer
wenn sie zu dritt sind Peter verachtet
weiterhin den Nebenbuhler Michael
Barbara sonst sich in der Anbetung ihres
Jüngers der ab und an von Ihrer Nähe ein
platonisch versteht sich natürlich auch
kosten darf Michael er taucht bald
komplett in den waren ab er schlägt sich
bei mystischen Riten unter dem Vollmond
die Nächte um die Ohren und er verliert
sich immer mehr in Glauben an das Böse
in Form ja das mächtigen katzenkönigs
Mirko zitieren uns doch gerne noch mal
kurz aus dem späteren Gerichtsurteil das
Urteil des BGH vom September 88 auf das
wir später noch zurückkommen Zitat sie
brachten ihn durch schauspielerische
Tricks vorspiegeln hypnotischer und
hellseherischer Fähigkeiten und die
Vorname mystischer Kulthandlungen dazu
an die Existenz des katzenkönigs der
seit Jahrtausenden das Böse verkörpere
und die Welt bedrohe zu glauben er in
seiner Kritikfähigkeit eingeschränkt
aber auch aus Liebe zu Haar darum bemüht
ihr zu glauben wenn er sich schließlich
außerkoren gemeinsam mit den beiden
anderen den Kampf gegen den Katzenkönig
aufzunehmen auf Geheiß musste er
Mutproben bestehen sich katholisch
taufen lassen und Haar ewige Treue
schwören
so wurde er von ihr und P zunächst als
Werkzeug für den eigenen Spaß benutzt
schon alles was ihr jetzt gehört habt
ist alles andere als spaßig verheerend
wird es als sie auf die Idee kommen
Michael nicht nur als Werkzeug für den
eigenen Spaß zu benutzen bald redet
Barbara auch in fremden zungenen sie
verliert plötzlich ihr Augenlicht bloß
um kurze Zeit später wie durch ein
Wunder wiedersehen zu können klarer als
je zuvor und sie sieht den Weltuntergang
der Katzenkönig spricht durch sie und er
ist sauer verdammt sauer so sauer dass
er die Welt vernichten will aber es gibt
eine Möglichkeit ihn wieder zu
besänftigen Achtung aus cut bitte zurück
in die Realität irgendwann in dieser
Zeit erfährt Barbara end dass ihr
Ex-Freund Udo n der sich nach ihrer
Aussage ja zu Abtreibung gezogen hatte
ganz in der Nähe wieder aufgetaucht ist
und auch noch geheiratet hat
wenn sie ist so scheint es eifersüchtig
auf diese Ehefrau vielleicht ahnt ihr
schon wen ihr Ex geheiratet hat richtig
die Floristin Annemarie n die ganz in
der Nähe ihren Blumenladen betreibt und
Michael das Spielzeug soll nun zum
Werkzeug ihrer Eifersucht und Rache
werden einen Weg gibt es den Katzenkönig
zu besänftigen und die Welt zu retten er
hat ihn Barbara offenbart er verlangt
ein Menschenopfer Wahnsinn
Wahnsinn mit Methode
was treibt Barbara h und auch ihren
geliebten Peter P wirklich an vielleicht
will P Michael R einfach nur loswerden
nachdem er ihn nun genug erniedrigt und
verarscht hat dem Ex seiner Freundin weh
zu tun und sei es um den Preis eines
Mordes scheint ihm auch recht zu sein
und man darf auch nicht vergessen dass
auch Peter P Barbara völlig verfallen
ist und alles für sie tun würde das ist
natürlich alles Spekulation aber wollen
Sie vielleicht auch einfach ausprobieren
wie weit sie gehen können wie viel Macht
sie haben ihm und Barbara wird man
nichts nachweisen können Sie werden
keinen Finger rühren und selbst
niemanden ein Haken sie haben einen Plan
Michael R ist williges Werkzeug in den
Händen von Barbara er weiß von ihrem
Deal mit dem Katzenkönig ein Opfer für
die Menschheit
eine unschuldige Frau muss durch seine
Hand sterben um die ganze Welt zu retten
alle Prüfungen körperlich und seelisch
hat er mit Fürbitte Barbaras bestanden
doch nun soll er Morden was einem tiefen
Glauben widerspricht seine Bedenken
schiebt er nur schwer beiseite und hat
wahnsinnige Angst vor der Tat aber noch
größer ist die Angst was passieren würde
wenn er mit dem göttlichen Auftrag
scheitert und die Welt mitsamt ihrer
Schöpfung vergeht Peter der Novize
seiner Herrin und selbst ein sehr weiß
dass dieses Töten ein gerechtes töten
ist der Tod von Annemarie n wird den
Katzenkönig auf Äonen hin wieder in die
Unterwelt verbannen
zufrieden mit dem Opfer wird er ein
ganzes Zeitalter ruhen
das fährt ein Messer wie schwer in
Peters Hand aber es ist sein Schwert
gegen das Böse Michael Erl steckt es
vorsichtig in seinen Hosenbund zurück
und dann klingelt er bei Annemarie n
und was dann geschieht haben wir euch
schon erzählt zehnmal sticht Michael R
auf Annemarie n ein sie überlebt schwer
verletzt er wird verhaftet in den
Vernehmungen suchen die Ermittler nach
einem Mordmotiv werden aber
verständlicherweise anfangs gar nicht so
richtig finde ich sie spüren nur
Erschütterung bei jemanden dessen
Weltbild zerfällt seine Mission ist ja
gescheitert aber die Welt die geht eben
gar nicht unter schließlich beginnt
Michael R doch zu sprechen und was die
Ermittler zu hören bekommen lässt den
Fall plötzlich in einem ganz neuen Licht
erscheinen denn kurz darauf werden auch
Barbara H&P verhaftet die beiden geben
sich anfangs unwissend und verneinen
jemals irgendwas mit einer Katzenkönig
Geschichte oder mystischer ritueller
hirnwäscherei zu tun gehabt zu haben sie
schieben alles auf Michael RR der
einfach verrückt sei beide glauben noch
immer mit diesem Verbrechen
durchzukommen denn schließlich haben ja
nicht Sie Annemarie ein angegriffen das
war doch Michael RR in seinem Wahn nein
sie wollten ihn sogar davon abhalten auf
diese verquere Art die Welt retten zu
wollen
aber bald bricht dieses Lügengebäude
unter dem Druck von Staatsanwaltschaft
und dem Gericht zusammen das Landgericht
Bochum entscheidet und Michael R wird
darauf zu zehn Jahren Haft verurteilt
außerdem wird seine Unterbringung in
einer psychiatrischen Anstalt angeordnet
Barbara h und Peter P bekommen
lebenslange Freiheitsstrafen fürs erste
muss man sagen da fällt mir ein Mirko
haben Barbara und Peter das eigentlich
ernst gemeint und selbst an diese
Katzenkönig Geschichte geglaubt oder
Michael von Anfang an für ihre Zwecke
missbraucht was meinst Du ja die
Richterin von damals meint die beiden
haben nicht nur vor Gericht versucht das
Ausmaß ihrer Manipulation
herunterzuspielen sie haben auch nie an
ihre eigenen Geschichten geglaubt der
einzige der wirklich in diesen waren
versunken war das war Michael RR alle
drei Angeklagten legen gegen das Urteil
Revision beim Bundesgerichtshof ein der
findet dann auch Fehler bei der
Strafzumessung in Bezug auf Barbara Haar
und Peter PI bestätigt ansonsten aber
insbesondere die Annahme der mittelbaren
Täterschaft der beiden Anstifter das
heißt eine eine Anstiftung die man zwar
nicht physisch feststellen kann die ist
aber gegeben hat
kannst du noch mal mit Deiner besten
juristenstimme zitieren diesen Abschnitt
sehr gern
mittelbarer Täter eines tötungs- oder
versuchten Tötungsdelikts ist jedenfalls
derjenige der mit Hilfe des von ihm
bewusst hervorgerufenen Irrtums das
Geschehen gewollt auslöst und steuert so
dass der Irrende bei Werten der
Betrachtung als ein wenn auch noch
schuldhaft handelndes Werkzeug anzusehen
ist ja also wenn ich das mal kurz in
meine Muttersprache zurück übersetzen
darf der andere durch Lügen und
Manipulation sozusagen zum Mordwerkzeug
macht der ist mit Schuld genauso kann
man es auch formulieren naja
Juristendeutsch ist eben was worüber man
leicht den Kopf schütteln kann aber ich
verstehe schon dass es im Gesetzen und
vor Gericht natürlich vor allem darauf
ankommt etwas genau so so genau wie
möglich zu fassen eine Verhandlung ist
ja halt wieder Poesie noch irgendein
kneipengespräch
was hast du sehr gut gesagt das
abschließende Urteil fällt schließlich
am 18 januar 1989 die Angeklagte Barbara
h erhält statt des anfänglich verhängten
lebenslänglich eine Haftstrafe von 14
Jahren Peter P 11 Jahre Michael R wird
zu 8 Jahren verurteilt und in einer
psychiatrischen Einrichtung
untergebracht
Sachverständige schließen damals bei
Michael R eine psychische Störung aus er
habe jedoch eine Zitat
hochabnahme Persönlichkeit
das in Kombination mit der erfolgreichen
Gehirnwäsche von Barbara h und Peter P
habe Michael in eine falsche Realität in
eine wahngewissheit geführt die als
schwere seelische Abartigkeit zu
kennzeichnen sei ja und diese üble
Geschichte die in einem grausamen
Mordversuch endet beschäftigt junge
Leute im Jurastudium bis heute genau der
katzenkönigfall ist ein viel diskutier
Vorgang für angehende Juristinnen und
Juristen und ein Exempel des Strafrechts
die Kernfragen der sich die am
Prozessbeteiligten stellen müssen waren
nämlich wer büßt für den Mordversuch und
können Menschen die sich völlig von der
Realität entfernt und in einem wirklich
verrückten Weltbild verirrt haben
haftbar gemacht werden wer ist am Ende
der wahre Täter eines solchen
Verbrechens der labile und psychisch
zerstörte Michael R oder die beiden
heimtückischen Menschen im Hintergrund
ich denke es war wichtig dass diese
komplett durch existiert werden diese
Kernfragen und auch immer noch werden
denn von ihrer Aktualität haben sie ja
nichts eingebüßt ich meine vom
Katzenkönig redet natürlich kein Mensch
mehr aber wenn man sich jetzt nur mal
anschaut was zum Beispiel durch q-annen
alles für ein Unsinn in die Welt gesetzt
wurde und eben auch geglaubt wurde und
sowas kann natürlich auch wieder mal
tödliche Konsequenzen haben und es gibt
es natürlich immer wieder dass Menschen
andere als Werkzeug für ihre eigenen
üblen Pläne missbrauchen der Katzenkönig
lebt also in gewisser Art und Weise
weiter
[Musik]
das ist wirklich ein düsteres
Schlusswort irgendwo zwischen düster und
komisch damit wollen wir mal euch noch
nicht entlassen vielleicht zum Schluss
noch mal ein schöner Cat Content Regie
könnt ihr mal irgendein schönes
katzengeräusch einspielen auf naja okay
ich dachte eigentlich eher an irgend
niedliches schnurren oder mir Hunde
Katzenbabys aber okay wir lassen dir es
dabei ist ja schließlich auch ein Krimi
Podcast also und damit sind wir am Ende
unserer heutigen Ausgabe angelangt und
danken Euch ganz herzlich dass ihr
wieder mit dabei wart die Geschichte vom
Katzenkönig haben wir erzählt anhand
einer Ausgabe des WDR true crime-formats
Mord Orte Beiträgen auf yurizu.de und
rolling planet.de sowie des Urteils des
Bundesgerichtshofes und damit
verabschieden wir uns bis zum nächsten
mal euer Mirko und euer Stefan